hi everyone
i'm vedica and i'm pursuing my m tech in
biotechnology from amit university
and i am a research fellow at pine
biotech so i will be talking about my
project today
the title of my project is
transcriptomic analysis of covid19
patients and their clinical data
so to begin with the coronaviruses are a
highly diverse type of transmittable
viruses
that infect humans and animals alike and
kids can cause mild to severe
respiratory infection
the ongoing pandemic that we are seeing
is the covid19 pandemic it is caused by
the noble beta corona virus strain cov2
it is a zoonotic origin and possesses
extraordinary threat to public health
safety and progress
the disease can be classified into three
to four stages which are as follows
number one is the asymptomatic stage
which includes the incubation period
from 1 to 14 days
number two is the mild disease which is
followed by symptoms like fatigue fever
cough etc
which can also progress to the moderate
disease where some dyspnea and
respiratory difficulty can be observed
it can also progress into severe stage
in some of the cases where some medical
attention and hospital admission may be
required
also
coming to the emergence and spread of
the disease in december 2019 according
to the timeline first 27 cases of a
viral pneumonia were documented in a
seafood market in wuhan
in january 2020 the chinese government
identified the pathogen as a new
coronavirus variant and towards the
later half of the month wha declared it
as a pandemic phaic alert and human
transmission was confirmed
it is suggested that the virus is of
natural origins and originated night
likely in humans
in the first quarter of 2020 the viral
infection had also reached india it has
occurred in three waves so far 3.6 crore
cases have occurred and the recovery
rate remains close to 98.18
to understand the structure of the virus
we would say that the virus has various
proteins like spike protein the envelope
and the membrane
followed by the presence of a nuclear
capsule inside in which the single
standard rna is contained
it also contains a replicase enzyme
orf1a1b which is of a fused orf thus it
has six functional orfs
which go in the order of five dash to
three dash
also several orfs encoding accessory
proteins were observed
coming to the genome sequence identity
analysis of the virus it was showed that
it shares maximum identity of up to 90
amongst all animals with bad virus
and coming to the viral taxonomy it says
79 identity with sars covet and 50 with
mercy ov
also initially it is the spike protein
of the virus that is responsible for its
antigenicity and recognition by the
ace which is the angiotensin converting
enzyme to receptors
the virus does enters the alveolar
epithelial cell with the lungs and it is
it is followed by replication and
subsequent migration down to the airways
which can progress to the lungs and the
respiratory the respiratory organs thus
it causes respiratory distress and
discomfort in patients
thus to uh
to
to analyze and develop therapeutic
targets against the cobit 19 disease it
is very important that we understand the
transcriptomic changes that are
associated with the clinical progression
of the disease
so with the a with the same aim a
pipeline was developed and all the
stages were carried out on the t bio
server of the
t bio server and various interactive and
interesting pipelines were followed that
gave very graphic results
the data set number
gse17867 was obtained from the jio
website
144 samples had progressive data which
means that
at day zero they had either asymptomatic
or mild disease
and at day five the disease had
progressed either to the moderate or
severe disease
the rest of the patients had only data
for one of the days amongst day zero and
day 5 and thus they were excluded from
the study
the q score of all the sequenced
uh sequence genes and and the ngs data
which had which was less than or equal
to 5 were removed
and with the some of the gene expression
was reduced and those with n value
greater than 10 percent were on only
included in the study
it was followed by the principal
component analysis step here first con
quantile normalization using the t bio
server was performed the log
transformation occurred and the
threshold was kept to less than five
followed by pcm
the differential gene expression
analysis can also be carried out which
converts raw reads statistic
statistically significant results
the law of two full chain values of
greater than one and less than minus one
were only kept
also as we compared multiple genes it
was important to look at the p existed
values and the fdr was kept to p less
than 0.1 so that only significantly
differentially expressed genes and
significantly
exp the down regulated and upregulated
genes were selected
thus after all the filtering and sorting
28 641 genes were taken for further
analysis
now the results were obtained
and
we performed a principal component
analysis which is basically it follows a
dimensionality reduction reduction
analysis
as
we have data across a lot of samples
across and a lot of patients and for
different uh types of genes that are
differentially expressed they form the
various components in pca
thus it is important to reduce the pca
the components into lesser number of
components to the formation of various
eigenvector matrices and interpret the
results as the same
we observed that a pc1 value of 21.47
was observed pc2 value of 15 15.47 was
observed and a subsequent pc3 pc4 pc5
p2 pc n values were also observed but
the highest pc values were taken to be
plotted amongst the x y x axis and y
axis respectively
the blue dots reflect the
plots and samples on day zero and the
and the red square dots depict the
progressive samples on days
so as we can observe in the graph the
pattern is observed as such that the day
zero samples
were observed in the second and the
third quadrant and the day five samples
were observed in the first and the first
fourth quadrant
in the graph
thus the pcs scatter plot says that
significantly differentially expressed
genes are observed in the mild and
progressive stage patients and the
significant difference is observed on
the pca plot by the segregation of the
plots in various models
the immunological profiling of severe to
moderate kubernetes patients is
characterized by increasing order of
density of the regulation of pathways
such as jack strat pathways cytokine
receptor interaction and hematopoietic
linings with which leads to pronounced t
cell lymphopenia
also it is important that host antiviral
responses are innate in nature and
involves cytokines and interferon
induced proteins
the key differentially expressed genes
that modulate the significant pathways
in genes are identified to various
degrees in moderate mild severe and
asymptomatic over 19 patients
all this can also lead to
the development of a hyper inflammatory
state
and
when the viral load was correlated with
the disease severity it showed no
significant correlation which also
states that uh even mild patients or
patients that have asymptomatic in my
disease are highly highly infectious
thus it is important to
to have steps like social distancing and
hygiene even in across all patients and
even non-infected people by varying of
mass etc to prevent the spread of the
same
so to conclude with i would like to say
that the transcriptomic analysis showed
that the transcriptome of stars covered
two infected cells reflected the
interplay between host and virus which
can provide valuable insights into
mechanisms underlying sars govid
infection development and the copenhagen
disease progression
the viral infection triggers a
large-scale host immune response and
leads to the up regulation and down
regulation of in hundreds and thousands
of gene of increasing order of severity
according to the types of pathways that
are involved
thank you so much
you